going back to the political terms we
talked about what where in that Spectrum
do you place yourself today
um what which of the label do you think
captures your political views
Progressive Social Democrat
um which which again is a capitalist I
own my own business I pay the taxes I'm
legally required to pay and not a penny
more and you know all those things
that's where I place myself would you
please yourself to the left of Joe Biden
yes yes
where does the AOC fit into that
it's a good question what do you think
about AOC as a candidate do you think
she eventually runs
I think that if she doesn't run into
some kind of Scandal and I don't mean
scandal in the sense of some personal
impropriety that you know but I mean
some kind of major political problem it
seems that she has the staying power to
be an American elected politics for a
long time whether she would even want to
be president versus maybe going to the
senate or being Governor or whatever the
case may be I have no idea what her
Ambitions are in that sense but
certainly like policy aside she has this
combination of charisma
likability to some
but also something about her personality
that angers the people who don't like
her in a way that only fuels her sort of
uh presence uh which I think applies to
Trump as well
um that I do think that she has the
potential to be to have significant
staying power in American politics
president I don't know do you think
that's the future of uh
political elections and politics in
general is people who are able to
skillfully piss off the other side like
AOC and Trump did I think it's an aspect
of it I think it's also understanding
how to communicate policy ideas
Trump I have things I can praise Trump
about if we want to get to that segment
at some point you let me know when that
is but I I do think that there are some
things Trump is very good at and this is
why it's very hard for me to believe
that Ron DeSantis has what it takes to
actually fight Trump in a national
primary and
um one of those things is Trump has a
even though he often says very strange
things that if you transcribe them you
go that's what language is that that
doesn't make any sense whatsoever in the
moment the way he relates to
um adversaries on stage Etc is very good
in that he is very much aware of how it
is going to be seen by the audience and
so that's why a lot of times it's more
about doesn't matter that a word salad
came out of his mouth how he immediately
responded and related to the person
who's very good so I think that knowing
how to be good when Clips are shared all
the time often out of context is
extraordinarily important knowing how to
use social media which every election
cycle that means something different
but understanding how to use social
media very important those things are
absolutely
so important and whether you're able to
do a deep dive on the deficit it's
certainly useful but I would say it's a
bad thing it's becoming less important
in terms of figuring out who we want to
represent us